اما زالت المعلومات تصل تباعا هنا في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه اكيف لم تتوقف صفراتها
الانذار عن الدويم منذ ساعات اكد عمده
المدينه فيتالي كليتش كو ان المدينه تعرضت
لهجوم بطائرات مسيره بلغ عددها الى حد
الساعه 20 طائره ادرون لم تتسبب في اي
خسائر بشريه بل استهدفت بعض البناء
التحتيه محطات التيار الكهربائي وتصفيه
المياه هو خلفت بعض الجرح وبعد الخسائر
الماديه مثل ما قلت همم هنا يتخوف كثيرا
الاوكرانيون من تكرر سيناريوات الهجوم
الذي قال العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ليله
الجمعه اكثر من 70 صاروخ من نوع كروز
استهدف المدينه وتسبب في قطع التيار
الكهربائي على 40 اكثر من 40% من سكان
المدينه
همم بخوف كبيره هنا وسط الاوكرانيين وقفنا
عليها منذ وصولنا يتخوفون من تجدد
العمليات العسكريه الميدانيه مطلعه هذه
السنه وكل الاعين اليوم موجهه سوف العاصمه
منزك وصوب اللقاء الذي سيجمع فلوديمر
فلاديمير عفوا همم بوتين الرئيس الروسي مع
نظيره همم
لوكيشنكو يتخوفون من ان تبدا العمليات
العسكريه من من الشمال ومن الحدود البلار
روسيا خاصه انه في الايام الاخيره وحسب
الجيش الاوكرانيه حلقت بعض الطائرات
البلار روسيه في عمليه استكشاف فهمت هنا
في اوكرانيا على ان همم
الثنائي بوتين ولوكاشينكو يحذرني لامر او
لعمليه ميدانيا
ليله امس ايضا تحدث مع بعض الشباب
والشابات والشابات الاوكرانيات الذين
يتخوفون من انهم سوف يقضوا عطله احتفالات
نهايه السنه همم في في وسط وسط اجواء وبرد
قارس خاصه بعد تشدد انقطاعات التيار
الكهربائي بسبب استهداف المحطات والبناء
التحتيه وكل المحطات همم التي تقوم
باطلاقه التيار الكهربائي للقذف المتكرر
هنا همم السلطات الاوكرانيه صباح اليوم
قالت ان عمليه اعاده توصيل التيار
الكهربائي سوف همم سوف تكون بالسهله خاصه
همم وراء بسبب تجده همم قصف همم المتكرر
على العاصمه الكريهه على كل حال
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه التوضيحات